i hear this all the time from people
saying that like you don't understand
tim the military and the police would
side with trump in two seconds it'd be
the shortest civil war in history and
i'm like have you ever actually gone
to these military bases and talked to
some of these people i know some who say
this have
and maybe their buddies in the military
are you know more conservative
but i've met tons of cops who would be
like i'll just do whatever i'm told
we've seen it two cops went and arrested
gym owners because the democratic
governor said to
so if trump said directive 51 is being
invoked because we're going to go
with china and covert you know destroy
this country and then one democratic
governor instructs the national guard or
the police to do something
unconstitutional or defy trump they'll
do it
it's not it's not about whether or not
there's enough fringe leftists it's that
we're already seeing it kate brown can
deploy her secret police and no one
cares
so that that's enough well there's a
difference between
where we're at now and what that would
mean because
you know there's still some semblance of
order and
when what you're suggesting when he
enacts
you know direct to 51 order would go out
the window
and then suddenly they'd be like let's
go because everyone would hear him
say it or if not i mean most i've i
would assume most policemen pay
attention
to the news and you know actually watch
trump's speeches
so they would probably hear it and they
would probably be like all right
if we're going to war and then all of a
sudden the governor calls and be like no
don't worry about china worry about the
feds
i have a feeling again i i'm just using
my own knowledge my own assumptions
of of the general american public
they're gonna be like okay
we know that we're going to war why are
we fighting each other still
in new jersey especially when it's just
a minority like i know you said
they they've infiltrated everybody this
far left they're they're
they're it's not even about that
necessarily okay so i was
at a gun shop and i was asking like what
do i need to know in terms of laws for
like you know buying the gun bringing it
home
and we got to talking and they told me a
story about a woman who lived in
philadelphia
for those that aren't familiar uh where
we live in south jersey it's
like very very close to the philly metro
it's philly suburbs
and about an hour from philadelphia is
atlantic city on the east coast of
south new jersey which is basically east
coast vegas like a lot of the same
restaurants a lot of same
casinos just you know east coast style
this woman lived in philadelphia
and phil pennsylvania has better gun
laws she had a concealed carry permit
and she made the mistake of not checking
the laws and she was like a new
you know relatively new gun owner she
was driving to atlantic city to go to
the casino and she gets pulled over
and the cop comes up to her and he says
how are you doing ma'am and she says
because she was taught this at her
school to inform the officer that she's
armed
and she said to the officer that she was
concealed caring and he says okay ma'am
can you step out of the vehicle for me
you're under arrest felony charge
four-year minimum
fortunately i guess the nra stepped in
and got the charges dropped it was a big
scandal that's the story they told me i
don't know if it's true or not
okay i bring it up because the second
amendment is clear
the the the right to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed
this woman was legally carrying a weapon
as pennsylvania as far as pennsylvania
was concerned
and she hopped over a bridge and all of
a sudden this cop said i don't care
about the constitution or the laws
you're under arrest felony charge i
don't equate i don't equate all cops to
any
one story about any cop i refuse to do
it i
i know so i know cops personally so when
across the friends that are cops
when across the country they've been
ticketing and arresting people for
violating the edicts of governors that
violate the constitution what do we call
it
they're following orders sure because
that's but that's not that's not the
same as if the president said
we're about to go to war i'm enacting
this directive 51 we got to come
together
so we can we can go against this enemy
this threat
head on together that's not that's not
where we are right now that's not where
we've been
people are afraid of this pandemic or
what was a pandemic you know whatever it
is it doesn't matter
now there's riots now the cops are
afraid to even be
cops because they're being attacked you
know this is an unprecedented time
you know you're you can't just like
apply this blanket thing like sure yeah
the the
the story of the one cop who was like
i'm just following orders you're
arrested
one cop you just told me a story about
this woman in the
philosophies yeah okay exactly i know i
know
yes sure you can give me all these
examples so how could i still personally
know cops that they won't do that out of
thin air i'm not marking anything up out
of thin air what are you talking about
how can you make up out of thin air what
you believe a cop would do when all the
evidence is to the contrary
and we have very little evidence of them
actually standing up for the
constitution because we've been talking
for months about the media and what they
portray
and what they give us what stories they
string along and push out into the open
so of course we're hearing about all the
bad cops
i know personally good cops that would
not do that
you're right i know that there's stories
out there of good cops that
that will that are not doing mandating
the mass they're not they're like we're
not going to be the mascot and there's
and there's the sanctuary cities in
virginia where the sheriffs were like
nope
right exactly the point is it will not
be
every cop saying you're right trump
we're with you it's going to be split
down the middle of a bunch of cops
saying i'll do whatever i'm told by my
boss
and a bunch of other cops saying i'll do
what the constitution mandates
so when virginia tried to pass these
laws that would seize guns the sheriffs
were like not on my watch
but then a bunch of other places they're
like i'll just arrest you in charge of
the fellaini i don't care what the
constitution says
there's a lot of cops who don't care
about doing what's right they care about
having a job
i mean you look at chicago this is
actually really funny when i was reading
about the launching of these new units
okay then they talked about on fox 32
disbanding one of their uh one of their
units because
it had been engaging in robberies and
home invasions
so like those cops right away are like
mob cops
sure those are like the worst of the
worst yeah i'm not i'm not saying that
it doesn't exist i'm not saying that
though there's cops out there that
that won't fall in line that won't go
okay
we're gonna follow the president who is
the the top dog as far as
who who runs it like that he doesn't run
the states and he doesn't run the local
department good point good point but
they're gonna ask their boss what to do
and and what you also understand is that
there are people who don't know anything
about what's going on and so you'll meet
a cop and you'll ask them like how do
you feel about what's going on and
they'll be like i don't know man these
riots are crazy
yet they'll still gladly arrest you for
a felony charge for for carrying a
weapon
in one of these states they call one of
the seven evil states i guess
that have these ridiculous restrictive
laws that fly in the face of the second
amendment
there's arguments about what it means to
be able to bear arms but
new jersey literally doesn't allow you
to bear arms well they do but you had to
jump through
no you can't bunch of hoops no you can't
oh not at all you can't not at all in
new jersey
you can own so the argument is that
you're allowed to bear arms
if well no no actually no you're
literally not allowed to period
yeah the weapon's got to be secured
separated from ammunition in its case
and you can only drive it to and from a
range or hunting
so they argue but you can haunt that
means you're bearing right that's not in
you so as long as you
no the point like the ultimately the
point is
when we see cops go and arrest gym
owners
in a small suburb because they wanted to
have a few people
exercising at their gym like that is the
most
insane thing i've ever heard that's why
i don't want to be in this
state anymore yeah i don't want to be
any blue state
so here's the issue if we've heard from
a ton of people when we talk about
standing up they say
you don't understand i have kids i have
to feed my family if trump
said he was invoking directive 51 to
secure the election because we're
a war is about to break out and we can't
have infighting and
chaos yeah and then the governor of this
state
told these officers you must do you
think they're going to be like well this
is the one time i'm going to say i don't
care about my family
no they're going to say i can't move i
don't have the money i need food and
i'll do what i
what i can to get food you take a look
at places like venezuela
where the military literally fire live
ammo at teenagers
because they're like if i don't i can't
feed my family so it's better to be on
the side of the government who
guarantees me food
than to fight with the people who would
create a better government which would
give everyone
food you know what i mean i'm saying
that
we have no guarantees about what will
happen and there's a good reason to
believe that people would split in
various factions and we have no idea who
would be on whose side
but to assume that people would just be
like there's the president let's go for
it is
is just i don't think there's any
evidence for that in fact there's
evidence at the contrary
reclaiming my time yes reclaiming my
excuse me tim
yeah i'm i it's my i'm reclaiming my
time now okay take it away
yeah uh excuse me i'm reclaiming my time
this is my time
i don't have my time is very limited all
right so i'm going to reclaim it
now look i i i don't i don't have
anything i just wanted to reclaim my
time let's talk about patreon
yes actually i do i'm gonna mention one
more thing
someone sent me this in context to
directive 51 it's called rex84
it's got a wikipedia entry and i'm going
to give it that much
okay i'm not saying it's true but it's
on wikipedia
sure wikipedia is supposed to be at
least somewhat of a decent information
aggregator
okay iraq's 84 is short for readiness
exercise 1984 was a classified scenario
and drill developed by the united states
federal government to detain
large numbers of u.s citizens deemed to
be national security threats
in the event the president declared a
national emergency
the plan was first revealed in detail in
a major daily newspaper
by reporter alfonso charti in july in
the july 5th 1987 edition
of the miami herald possible reasons for
such a roundup
were reported to be widespread
opposition to a u.s military invasion
abroad
such as if the u.s were to directly
invade central america
to combat what the government perceived
as subversive activities
the plan also authorized the military to
direct order
direct ordered movements of civilian
populations at state and regional levels
according to professor diana reynolds
existence of a master military
contingency plan of which rocks 84 was
apart
garden plot and similar earlier exercise
lantern spike
were originally revealed by journalist
ron reidenhauer
who summarized his findings in an
article in counter spy
they go on to say that contingency plans
by the us government for rounding up
people perceived by the government to be
subversive or a threat to civil order
have existed for many decades
for example from 1967 to 1971 the fbi
kept a list
of over 100 000 people to be rounded up
as subverses dubbed the addicts list
this is also on wikipedia too yeah it's
how you get conspiracy theorists because
the government has plans for this stuff
yeah i remember like man 15 years ago
alex jones ranting about the fema
facilities that are prepared to take in
a bunch of subverses and stuff
i don't know a whole lot about it i just
knew the guy used to rant about it all
the time
okay these could be i don't know their
sources for this
you know maybe nobody maintains these
what is this the norton company what are
their sources and all this stuff the
intercept okay well the intercept is
real
rex 84 what's their source for this uh
i don't know what that is archive what's
their first source
well they have three sources i mean oh
so that that's old school and press
south and private i used to be right
better than yes so this
my fear about this kind of stuff and
even with directive 51
there was there was wording in both of
them that said the federal government
and in directive 51 the president can
enact it but then
the congress can enact it also and kind
of check the other one
right in 51 yeah in 51 it says no no the
national
the national emergencies act oh okay it
was a different act yeah but it's
basically the same thing but for
congress instead of the executive branch
approach
except if the president declared that he
was the coordinator above all branches
then they're going to be like no you're
not we have the power and say no you're
not i have the power
and the executive branch is the branch
that actually deals with
going aft like enforcing laws and things
like this
so if there were people loyal to trump
they'd be like okay
this is the important factor man matt
taube wrote about this the counting
heads phase and the scenario he
describes
is you'll you'll see two black cars
speeding as fast as possible through
washington dc
yeah they'll both crash and then people
jump out run full speed to the
you know the dc police bureau and yell
at the cop arrest this man to the other
guy
and that's when the authority is
challenged the police are going to be
like uh
and eventually they have to choose who
they're going to actually arrest
this is sounding an awful lot like tympo
wars but these things are real i'm not
i'm not talking about
you know this is matt taibbi's writing
yeah like here's no no i get you're just
saying though what people need to
realize is that
it's one thing when everything's calm
and normal okay to be screaming about
aliens and all this other stuff it's
another thing when we're experiencing
an economic shutdown 130 somehow days
massive economic collapse
potential war with another country we
are in unprecedented times
yes we are at this point to speculate as
to whether or not the president will
declare a national emergency to enact
emergency executive authority
is not outside of the realm of
possibility i agree it's
in fact i would argue it's potent it's
very likely well especially when
the his direct opponent also is
yeah i don't know if can we even talk i
mean the whole obamacare thing is like
it's pretty insane with the right the
actual
proof that they have of them colluding
to
and bring them down bill barr has just
said he will not wait until after the
election to reveal
durham's the durham report the
investigation and there's two people
investigating the whole thing too right
it's very possible that in october
durham releases his or maybe even
september releases his report
and it says obama was involved biden was
involved these are criminal actions
there's
indictments all of this crazy stuff yeah
which triggers a massive wave
riots whatever who knows maybe not it's
also possible the durham investigation
says you know what nothing happened
yeah i really don't think so considering
the conf you know the confirmed report
that's come out but maybe
i mean i i still hold hold to the fact
that i think biden's gonna retire at the
end of august
i think the dnc is gonna because it's
not over yet once
there's like a day or two left they're
gonna be like well
biden is actually slipping you all see
he's an old guy we're gonna have to
we're gonna have to let him go and
he's gonna retire so good good on you
thanks for holding the place
while we've done while this country has
been ravaged
thanks let's let's i'll make one very
important
point over the past almost four years
wow longer than four years man when the
start of the russia
allegations against trump you know in
2015 i think it was
the mainstream media has been telling us
that our president
was secretly colluding with russia to
subvert our government
that is one of the most insane things i
have ever heard
going so far as msnbc actually hosted a
guy
who said trump may have been you know a
russian asset he believes
since 1984. wow well but he was like
maybe not but it's like why would you
even entertain that's ridiculous
yeah maybe not wait what now either you
have proof or you don't saying something
like that that's insanity so
especially when they prove they've
proved that all of this is bs go ahead
let's weigh the conspiratorialness of
the claims
donald trump according to jonathan chait
uh he believes
was an asset of the russian government
since the 1980s very conspiratorial
the president may enact a national
security provision to defend the country
because we've had mass death and
economic collapse
okay that's not a conspiracy that's like
that's just will he do it or won't he
he can because it's actually an order
that uh
whether or not whether or not it's
constitutional and there have been
others
and apparently a bunch of the
information pertaining director 51 is
secret you can't read it
so it like references annexes like refer
to these annexes and it's like oh but
those are confidential you won't know
yep and i'm not surprised because it's
supposed to preserve the country yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode